Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: Oh,
look at this rated-G movie? Well this looks very
good yeah like this g-movie
and can you put that in there
because cause want to know
what Martin Scorsese has done.
Film Courage: Are most great
stories an outsider story?
Tony: I don't know. I feel like I'm an outsider
and feel like almost everyone I know feels like
an outsider at some point in their life if not
often probably more than 50 percent of the time.
Maybe that's why we can kind of
gravitate toward outsider stories.
We look at us film like Mean Girls or
something and it's about people just
trying to be together and fit in. We have this
urge to be together and part of the tribe and so
the outsider story is fun to play with but don't
think any of us want to be an outsider but it's
fun to watch the outsider because we feel
like we're outsiders. Does that make sense?
Film Courage: It does. I'm trying to think
of the movie just watched from the is it
pump up the volume the Christian
Slater. Here he's this radio
guy and everybody kind of worships him because
he just says whatever he wants and they can't
believe what they're hearing and then the the
faculty [at his school] is just incensed by it.
Then in real life he's this awkward guy
that he wants to be part of the group but
then he's kind of turned off by that whole
suburbia high school hierarchy thing and it
just had me thinking about that just sort of
this guy that actually when you listen to him
he spoke to everyone but then for whatever reason
he was too scared at the the high school to
yeah try to navigate the social hierarchy yeah
and but but we we have these these hero stories
where are they always the outsider guess maybe
that's what makes the the hero's arc is that
guess yeah guess in order for mean for the most
part when we have our heroes journey and think
it's a singular hero think it's because we could
we can relate to the problems of one person for 90
minutes if you bring in too many people or the the
ensemble cast there tends to be a veering towards
the one person that's really pushing it all the
way through so we we have to have that we also
almost have to have that mirror who's my mirror
here oh it's Cameron Diaz okay great I'm with her
on this journey and that's and don't think that's
real life in any way at all but for well we're all
our own heroes in our own journeys but we're
also collective but so guess our protagonist
is an outsider of sorts because the protagonist
needs to be spun around they need to be pushed
back on their heels and that's why we're
interested it's just like oh wait they spun around
they're dizzy how do they stop being dizzy okay
that's fun now how do turn the page or sit here
for another 10 minutes to find out what the next
two scenes are because that was interesting what
peril is this character going to be in so yeah
it would make sense that the characters would be
outsiders this during covid we we have all these
the the movies I've watched have not been movies
would watch there are comfort movies and the wrong
missy came out the David Spade movie that Adam
Sandler produced and and it's not a movie I'd go
run to see but watched it and it's just he is he
is an outsider he's he's in his own tragedy it's
a comedy but he's in the utter tragedy of thinking
that he found the it's really formulaic and like
you like if just told you two or three description
you'd be like oh so the act one is this act
two is exactly as this it's like yeah it is
but it's fun to watch them get there what movie
protagonists do do you feel the most connection to
could be male or female well so when was young and
this was there was this movie called Johnny Suede
Brad Pitt starred in it that
came out and Tom DiCillo
wrote it and look at it now and
it's absurd and it's hilarious
but at the time was thought was Johnny Suede
am it was Brad Pitt's first leading role
and and it's just about a guy who's trying to
figure out love and wants to get a band together.
I’m like that's me and it's just kind of silly
because it's a he's really kind of a dopey
character and not I don't know why gravitated
to him so much think it was because was trying
to figure out love and was kind of always wanted
to have getting a band together is like getting
group of friends together just like how do we how
do we how do a bunch of guys come together and
not make love well let's just get a band it's it's
everything's kind of intimacy so he was trying to
find his intimacy and blowing it beyond belief and
so when think of a character that gravitated to
when was when was young it was
it was johnny suede and had the
yeah it's Tom DiCillo got to interview him like
15 years ago and he's written books too and
brought every single book I'm like please sign my
books now he lives in LA so I still have to like
yeah anyway he's a I'm a huge fan of his
and I'm a huge fan of how honesty is about
his career as a filmmaker and how
really rough and tumble it was
and just the beauty of johnny sway in his other
movie living in oblivion which came out after that
and sorry you were still in the church at the
time you saw it okay yeah were and you didn't tell
anyone that you saw the movie was very careful
yeah because it was rated r oh so had to go to the
video store actually think bought the VHS bought
the VHS and that and I watched that thing that's
probably the movie I've seen the most in my life
and could probably give you every line of dialogue
from here the reason watched it was because
one of my favorite singers is in it Nick Cave
so that was what turned me onto it and then all of
a sudden I'm like well that character spoke to me
so wow would you hide the movie somewhere yes yeah
yeah hide the hide the movies hide the records
yeah where would you hide them if not to I
actually had my own apartment at that time so
so it was easy enough but when was like still
living at home it was records behind the dresser
and we would make mixed tapes for our friends
and then we'd hide the mixtapes but we would
all trade the tapes and then we'd keep the records
at certain friends houses move them back and forth
wow and it's just because they were rated r that
was for music and that's because they were punk
rock and that was something that would that no
one would understand movies know movies wouldn't
even bring into the house that were rated r but
would try to would would go to the video store
and this was this is when was married I'd go to
the video store and then would like look around
to make sure no one from the congregation was
around and then would like and then I'd pick
up oh look at this rated g movie well this looks
very this looks very good yeah like this g movie
can you put that in there because because
I want to know what Martin Scorsese's done
and then yeah then went to the library constantly
and was just checking out every movie that
stuff like I'd never seen apocalypse now and it's
just never and didn't know what a war movie was
thought war movie was just violence and
terrible and it's just like oh no these
are crafted films and so but would have to
watch them on my own and be very careful yeah.